Beth kobliner is one of the nation's
leading authorities on personal finance.
I measure this fact by the fact
that she's been on sesame street,
which I find pretty, I'm pretty
star struck now. In addition,
she also served on President Obama's
Advisory Council for financial capability
for young Americans.
So however you want to measure it,
Beth knows what she's talking about.
So please welcome Beth Kobliner.
Okay.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thanks so much for, for coming.
You've been on a pretty
big book tour so far.
I was in Detroit, Chicago, Atlanta,
um,
Ann Arbor,
and now I'm going for the next leg
leaving on Thursday to the west coast.
So a lot,
a lot going on.
It's fascinating to be meeting
parents with kids of all ages.
I look at you all his
kids. Um, and so I, uh,
yeah, no, it's great. I wanted to just
say two quick things. Is that okay?
Just to start really, the first
is, um, my dad is in the audience.
He's 87 years old.
Harold's Kobliner.
Okay.
And it's very cute. Cause my
dad among, he was an educator,
a principal then chairman of,
it's called the board of examiners,
which was the organization
that tested teachers,
principals and superintendents
in New York City.
And he also was a great role model about
money and he loves to this day to go
into the local supermarket and hand out
flyers about my book to anyone he meets.
He actually single handedly sold four
copies in Barnes and noble on the upper
west side yesterday. Just like talking to
parents. Oh my daughter wrote this book,
Simon and Schuster said we had a real
spike in south on the upper west side. Um,
and so he hands out fliers and he always
gives them to people in stores who he
really likes and who are helpful.
And,
and in addition to giving him like
the freshest soy milk in the back, um,
they also often say to him,
thank you for teaching me the secrets.
I didn't know these basic money issues.
Um,
and that's always been very touching
to him and touching to me and my mom.
And,
um,
I just wanted to say that the reason
I wrote the book was basically to like
share that wisdom that I grew up with
and had been writing about for 30 years,
uh, with people. So that
was the first thing. And the
second thing is, okay, yeah,
I'm, I'm, I'm old.
So I've been on Oprah and taught
Elmo about money and you know,
met with President Obama about children
and money. But the one thing now,
my daughter's 21 and my son's
18 and the little one's 13.
And the one thing they've
been impressed by, I'm like,
I'm speaking at Google today.
And they're like, no. Wow. Wow.
So Google,
I've never been,
it's really exciting and I
know how smart you all are.
Thanks. And I, we definitely do still,
I'm sure I have things to learn from this
book. Maybe one or two. I don't know.
I felt like I learned a lot reading it.
Um,
cause the book works off the premise that
parents should be teaching their kids
good money habits from preschool
all the way through young adulthood.
And you say in the book that a child's
basic money habits are formed by the age
of seven,
which I hope is not terrifying to any
parents of 10 year olds in the audience.
Sorry. Um, what,
what sorts of things are kids under seven
picking up on that are really locking
in those habits?
Well, there's some really good research
done by a woman named Corrine Holdin at,
uh, University of Wisconsin.
And I met her on sesame street,
I should say. I met her on the
street, sesame street. Um, but I did.
And she's done some remarkable research
looking at what three year olds
understand and she found,
they understand exchange when you
give money for something more.
Like if you give a card for something,
they get something back.
They see that happening. They
understand value. You know,
a diamond ring is more
valuable than a pair of shoes,
although it depends upon what
shoes you're talking about. And um,
also they understand the basic
concept of needs versus wants.
So if you go shopping in a supermarket
with a young child, you can say,
you know what,
we really need milk.
But we really want chocolate milk
or we really need vegetables,
but we really want potato chips and
we're going to spend most of our money on
things we need. And you could
play the game, need, want
game. And then, um, you know,
as a kid gets older, he was
like, how do we find the,
the less expensive brand and what are
the trade offs and all those sort of
things you could do in a supermarket.
But I think it's key that talking
to kids at very young ages,
like,
you know,
as little as three really has an impact
on having them understand these concepts
more and more. Um, which is really,
you know, I was surprised by that.
I didn't really realize
that. Um, and then the,
the scary one was a Cambridge University
did a study and they said by age seven,
many of those behaviors that we associate
with money habits are actually set by
age seven.
So I think they're talking more about
like delayed gratification and executive
function,
but it's not that it's absolutely set.
There's a lot of, there's a lot more to
teach an eight year olds up. Um, I think,
and that comes from everyday moments,
you know,
whether it's talking to your kid about,
okay,
I'm going to go buy a car. It's my editor.
He got my buck. And he's like, you know,
I,
I never would've thought of that,
but I brought my 10 year old
to the dealership because
I would think actually be
bored. But I brought her and I
started telling her, oh, okay,
well having to buy a car, this is what
the price is. I'm gonna try to negotiate.
I'm gonna interest rate. Maybe I'll go
to a bank for the interest rate or mean.
And those conversations are, are,
and those experiences frankly,
are pretty meaningful
for kids. You know, it's,
it's with everything digital and online.
I think it's,
it's really essential that parents
start doing that at many ages.
You know,
as kids get older.
Yeah. To a certain extent.
That sounds like an extension
of good parenting. Right?
Oh, absolutely. And to your kid, why
you're doing what you're doing, right.
Let them into those decisions. Yeah. Um,
make sure that things that would otherwise
go and spoken or sort of explained
and gratified what happens to a kid
who's parents don't consciously make an
effort to teach them
about money and finance.
Yeah. I mean, what we're seeing
is, so two years ago, uh,
the government participated
in the international test
for 15 year olds at it's
called Piza is the test.
And what was ironic,
I was on the president's
council at the time and like,
we couldn't come up with a $200,000 to
participate in this test, which is like,
okay, we as a government, but we did and
we were able to take this test, you know,
and,
um,
we found that 15 year olds in
the United States are mediocre,
like right in the middle. So their
countries, many, many countries, uh,
from all over that I'm doing
so much better than we are
in teaching kids basics.
And we're talking basics,
understanding the interest
rate on a credit card or
even being able to dissect a
paycheck, like not understanding
where that money's going,
whether it's, you know,
social security or tax or,
so I have in my book a chart on
all that. Um, but I also, you know,
it's so clear that our
nation by not under,
you know, someone I work
with said Pr, you know,
financial rights are civil rights and
if you understand that it's a mistake to
get into credit card debt that's charging
you 18% or if you understand that if
you miss a student loan payment,
that will likely go on your credit
record for seven years. You know,
those kinds of things.
I've had so many people tell me I didn't
know and I want my kids to know and to
understand this, you know, at
an age appropriate ways. Okay.
Yeah. It's interesting where
you say, you just said that, um,
one way of looking at it is that,
you know,
financial issues are civil rights issues.
Cause you mentioned a
statistic in the book that, um,
nearly half of all Americans couldn't
pull together $2,000 for a number of,
and this isn't just half of all Americans
don't have $2,000 in the back plate,
but they wouldn't be able to
borrow it from friends and fam,
like they could not get
right to can even get it.
Like you think, Oh, use your credit card.
They didn't have access
to credit to get $2,000.
So it probably means that they,
we don't know exactly,
but probably means that they, they are in
credit trouble and they were no longer,
no longer had a line of credit.
So when you think of that,
that's pretty terrifying.
It's like financial,
I've heard a call financial fragility
or finance, like we're so, uh,
um, unsecure. We're
not financially secure.
And I think that is so important.
Just the concept of, you know,
saving up money and, and I,
the more I've been touring,
I really strongly believe,
oh, and your Google,
you could make it help me make this
happen. I think cash is cash to come back.
I really think that I'm not getting
any nods or like, Nah, but when,
you know,
when I was a kid,
my parents would sit at the kitchen table
and my mom and dad would pay the bills
together and there were a pile of bills
and they'd write a check and the balance.
How many people here balance a
checkbook? Honestly, one person.
So interesting. My Dad could stand up
and tell you how many over 87 years,
how many times he found errors
in the bank math. But anyway, so,
um,
and I know you're all making a decision
of like time versus money and you know,
my time is worth more than checking to
find the $10 mistake. So, but you know,
sometimes there are mistakes
and I think for kids, you know,
my favorite story in the book as a mom
going to target with her son and he was
about eight or nine and she was buying
juice boxes and she pulled out a 20 and
her kids and mommy don't pay for it. Use
the card, you know, that's the way to,
you get it for free if you use the card.
And I think that mindset,
particularly for younger kids and of
course now Venmo and all the ways people
are exchanging money without exchanging
money. And we know that, you know,
MIT did a study years ago showing that
people spend twice as much if you use a
card then if you use cash.
Um,
and I think the pain of paying is
something when you fork over dollars,
it feels like, oh, I'm really giving up
something that's a behavioral economics.
Um, uh, finding. So I think the,
the inability to make a connection between
I'm buying things and I'm going into
a bank and getting money instead of
it all being online or I'm, you know,
I think that that is something that
children are missing out on and a great
parent would say, Hey, come on
over. I'm paying the bills online,
but it doesn't really look like any
different to a four year old or five year
old.
And you know,
someone doing work because it's hard to
sort of make that connection versus the
concrete experience.
So you in the book you advocate for,
you advocate against giving, you
know, middle schoolers and teenagers,
prepaid debit cards, like
have them work on cash. Yeah.
But it sounds also like adults would
benefit from working in cash to,
you know, or at least modeling
it for your child. I mean,
that's how I learned to make change.
My,
I had about four jobs in high school
and one of them was working at the local
diner this spring. I'm from
Queens originally. And um,
uh, that was one of my first jobs and
no, it was an AP math. Um, but I don't,
I'm not, that was my top subject. We
both bonded. We went to Brown, so,
but English major, but when
I was, uh, making change,
I remember that somebody,
it would be like $3 and 84 cents
bill and they'd give me a 10.
So I try to like subtract it in my
head and me and my dad's like, no,
you just count up. If it's 34
cents a penny for 35 then you know,
counting up all the way to $10.
And I learned that with cash.
And I think just the counting people,
not under a little kids,
not knowing coins or dollar bills.
I think that's all part of it.
And I think that is all important.
Um,
not that we will get rid of our credit
cards. They're super convenient,
but you know, if you're of course using
a credit card and paying it off in full,
it's good to do that.
It's good to have a credit record.
But I think that that's been pushed.
We too early and I think
kids are missing out. Yeah.
You, you're, so we've already touched on
a couple of specific bits of advice. Um,
a big one that comes up in the book
that I thought was really interesting
because it's one that is like so
distant in my memory is allowances.
So what is your take on giving
kids in allowance? Like, what are,
what are the learning opportunities
there? What do you say about that? Right.
So this study, um, at
University of Minnesota, uh,
and I have to say this one wasn't
a randomized controlled study. Um,
but it was interesting and that they
follow children who were given chores when
they were little and they,
you know,
whether it's making the bed or whatever
they were doing regularly and they found
that having chores not tied to money
but just chores as part of a family.
That's your responsibility. We're
a team. We're all in together.
That was one predictor of
a child's success in terms
of certain milestones like
graduating from high school or graduating
from school in general or starting a
career that that experience of
doing a job as part of a family,
um, was quite important
to a child's development.
But when you put money into the equation,
you give kids money for chores.
It takes away from that intrinsic value
of I'm going to work hard for my family.
We're in this together and it dilutes it.
Um,
same with um, Roland Fryer, great guy.
He did research on giving
kids money for grades.
How many people got money for grades?
Like most of you,
not because your parents said you work
hard and they do it the way you were born
with it or you are instilled with it.
This is a desire to work hard for
working hard sake. And you know,
maybe they're like,
we all knew like one day I'll
get to Google and you did it.
But I think that idea of parents
instilling that in kids. So that's,
it doesn't work. Roland fryer
in a wonderfully, you know,
randomized controlled study.
So that giving kids money and saying,
I'll give you an a,
I'll give you 100 bucks if you get an a
or 50 bucks if you get a doesn't work.
Is it the same for a gift or another
another kind of reward if you are award
afterwards, that's different. Okay.
If the kid does really well and you just
want to take them out for ice cream,
that's a different thing. But if
it's given as an incentive, yeah,
any kind of gift or award is,
doesn't work.
But so the question of allowance,
so given that you want to give allowance,
you can give allowance. And I looked
into um, two dozen studies on allowance.
There were international studies and
one like one from Canada found that when
people give their children allowance,
the kids end up being a little more
responsible with money and they save a
little more.
That study from England founds when
parents give their kids allowance,
the kids are feeling more
entitled and they're not.
So there is sort of no right
one right answer with allowance.
But what I have found overall is you want
to be clear to your child and in your
own mind what this allowance is for.
So if it's like a really little kid,
like a 10 year olds, it's good to say,
okay, this is going to be you have,
you know, six Lego kits.
If you want another one,
it's not your birthday and it's not the
holidays and grandma and Grandpa and
getting it from it.
You have to save up for that and you and
you figure out what that would roughly
cost.
Um,
cause I think one mistake parents
can make is I think back I go,
when I was a kid,
I got a dollar for babysitting and now
people get $20 an hour for babysitting.
So sort of thinking of
what it really costs, um,
and then having kids make choices and
you can buy the Doritos on your way home
and you learn opportunity costs or you
could put that dollar into a jar or a
piggy bank or whatever and save it up.
And then kids see that excitement
of building up that money.
So I think allowance works like that.
You can also give just a regular
allowance once a week. Um,
the rules of thumb are give a kids' age.
You know,
10 year old gets $10 a week,
but you know what I'm talking about
this in the Midwest, the moms are like,
I would like $520 handed to me a year.
So it really just depends.
Um, I think, um, you know, as a parent,
we really got most serious about this
when our kids were going to college and
said, okay, how do we come up
with the realistic amount, uh,
that they were lucky they don't have to
take out student loans and they are in a
situation where we will pay
for their healthcare and books.
But so if we wanted to get, you know,
they, they work, they both work.
But if we give them a little bit of
cash for that semester, how much,
you know, we should it be and
what would it be expected for.
So of course I'm like, oh, let's him $100.
And then we were thinking
about it or like, no,
this is money for if they want to go on
a trip with a friend or they want to go.
Um, so my daughter for example, when
skiing, even though she doesn't ski too,
kids get these days, um, she
went, uh, over winter break,
a bunch of friends were going to
Canada and they were driving up,
but she had to go later.
So she,
you saw her sitting there looking at
the train versus the plane and the train
took nine hours and the plane took two
hours and she made the choice to take the
train. And of course I'm thinking,
ah, we'll just let her take the plane.
It's a law. And then my husband
and I were talking about, no,
this was to each other. We did do this
in front of her, but that the idea that,
you know,
this is what we agreed to and this is so
good for her to be making those choices.
And she felt she had fun on the train.
She looked like looked out the window
and I did my homework and I read a lot.
I read a novel. And so those, I think
at every level when you're a parent,
the hardest part is coming up with
something and then sticking with it.
Yeah, that consistency.
Consistency. There's a,
there ends up being a
big shift though around,
I dunno if it happens in middle school,
like babysitting jobs are in high school.
Once I remember just
like waiting and waiting,
waiting to be 16 so I could get
a job. I was so excited. Um,
but it seems like from the research
you found there, it's a mix of,
you know, some benefits but also some
possible sacrifices with high school jobs
especially, you know, during
the school year. Right, exactly.
There are a lot of great books in the
last few years have come out that talked
about kids are,
you know,
they're coddle too much and they should
be out working in high school like we
used to do.
And that I agree with for sure in
theory and in practice. However,
um, the Department of Labor Statistics
did an analysis and they found that if a
child is working like 12 hours,
13 hours a week,
then it doesn't have a negative
impact on their grades. In fact,
it may give them a teeny boosting grades
and it could be because they're using
their time efficiently are. But once
you get to that 15 hour or over mark,
it has an impact on grades.
So we know that when you know,
kids do less homework in math there
it's a direct correlation to their math
grades. And then of course when
we're talking about, you know,
thinking about college and, and not
just how great a school you get into,
but also,
you know,
which will give you the most aid and
opening up your opportunities to get more
aid. I think it's, it's a hard trade
off. And of course there are many, many,
many families that need their
child to work, um, when,
uh, to, to the family.
But I think it's important just to
know that number where's in college
interestingly,
um,
you can work up to 20 hours kids who
work up to 20 hours but work on in an on
campus job have slightly higher GPA
than kids don't. That don't work at all.
Yeah.
And,
and then there's also the question of
is that work important preparation for,
for future careers and things like
that. Right. And so you and the book,
I think you advocate for college
students working during the summer,
maybe trade off for working less
during the school year. Absolutely.
I think working in the summer
for high school and you know,
college and then that job
during high school for example,
if it's during the summer, um, it's
sort of a great way to then segue to,
um, with your kids to, uh, the
magic of compound interest,
which is a hard one to,
you know,
talk like talk to a 14 year old about
this is great compound interest.
Um,
and you,
and the idea is if a child is say,
you know,
14 and they work every summer and maybe
they earn $1,000 for that summer and
they work for four summers in a row and
if they put that money into like a Roth
Ira, uh, and in order to open a
Roth Ira, you need to have income.
So it has to be from the job. So you put
that thousand dollars in each year, uh,
for four years and then you stop
and never put money in again.
You would most likely,
if you put it in an index fund or ETF,
and I talk about those in my book,
you know,
you would have be likely to have
over a hundred thousand dollars.
So saying that to a kid, you know,
you do it for these four years,
that's how much you're going to have.
That's fairly compelling
I think for many kids. Um,
and also it helps if you're applying for
financial aid because colleges expect
you to contribute much more of a
kid savings then apparent savings.
So, but if it's in an IRA, they don't
look at that money typically, which is,
you know, a little, it's a
good thing to know. Yeah.
There there's so many trade offs
with, sorry. No, no, no. It's,
it's all really clear in the book though.
There are a lot of like little worksheets
and tables that I found really,
really helpful. Um, and you know, we were,
we were saying the book starts or includes
in every chapter ways to introduce
these ideas to a preschooler,
whether it's just like playing with
coins or talking about wants and needs,
but you also take all of the advice
past college into young adulthood.
Um, and so, um, you know,
how much input on a 23,
24 year olds financial life do you
think a parent should be having? Um,
I think a lot of guidance is needed,
uh,
either because they didn't talk about
it before or kids are graduating. And,
you know, if you don't mind
me asking one more question,
how many people here have loans
that they're still paying off
the brown major? We're talking
about Grad school to Grad school,
including Grad school.
No, you all paid it off.
But I think that many,
many people graduate from college with
lots of student debt and if it's federal
student debt,
a lot of wonderful repayment options.
And I met someone here who worked at,
uh,
one of these companies that will
also refinance private student loans.
Typically if you're from a school that
they sort of makes the list of schools
that they think those kids have a
likelihood to pay off their debt too.
It's interesting,
but I think that um,
talking about repayment options, moving
back home is something that, you know,
it's so interesting. I'm Wa one part of
the country. I said, you go to college,
you have to move back
home. And they're like, ah.
And then another part of the country,
it was, I actually spoke to these kids,
it's called um, uh, uh,
college advising core.
And these are kids who graduate
from high school and they,
it's like a peace corps,
but for working in low income high
schools that don't have college counselors
and these kids volunteer for two years
and they learn as much as they possibly
can about being a college counselor
and helping kids with financial aid.
And when I sort of said, well, move
back home, you know, kids said,
I'm from the Bronx and I
have four siblings and we
live in a one room apartment,
I can't move back home. So I'm like,
okay. So the perspective there can be,
but I do think there's so much
we can do to educate people.
I mean,
I have one quick story about my dad
and a lot of the book is about delayed
gratification. And you know,
the marshmallow experiment, um,
that, uh, Walter Michelle is a
professor. He was at Stanford,
now he's at Columbia. And he started, uh,
he did an experiment with five year olds
and he put a marshmallow in front of
them and then he said, look, you can
eat this marshmallow now, feel free,
but if you wait, I'm going to
bring you a second marshmallow.
And they did this when kids
are five and they found,
and then he tracked these kids for years
and years and years and now those kids
are in their 50s. But when he did that
experiment, he'd walk out of the room,
you know, the examiner would walk out of
the room and some kids would be like, oh,
you know,
they eat the marshmallow right away.
But some kids would wait and they'd wait
and they wait and they would usually,
you know, whistle or try to
distract themselves. And,
and then they would wait for
him for 15 minutes to come back.
And they got that marshmallow,
that second marshmallow,
and they found that those kids who waited
had on average 200 points higher on
their sats.
I feel like I should start a prep course,
like an sat course.
With that in mind,
I don't know how someone here could
help me figure it out. Um, you know,
200 points higher on their sats. They, uh,
reported having happier lives,
better relationships,
and lower body mass indexes.
So that ability to delay
gratification is kind of incredible.
Is the idea that it's intrinsic or that
it's learned very early? Great question.
If I say this as a, as a
marshmallow, loving five-year-olds.
Well, that's the great
question. So what, um,
what we know is it wasn't that these
kids had this higher moral code or they
were even, oh, I could just
deny myself. They were,
it was more of a executive function.
The ability to sort of,
I'm going to pretend that's
not really a marshmallow.
I'm going to pretend there's a,
it's a picture of marshmallow or I'm
going to pretend there's dirt on it and I
don't want it anymore. Or I'm gonna
pretend I'm a superhero and I'm strong.
I could, you know, all
these different ways.
And now with the research is looking at
is how do we teach that? Can we teach it?
Um,
and you know,
I was brought up in an environment where
my dad was a teacher at this time in
1969 and he came home and told my mom,
okay,
New York City introduced a new pension
plan and we're going to put away a half,
50% of our income in this pension plan.
So we lived in Queens,
tiny little house.
My Dad earned like
$30,000 at the time I had,
they had three kids, a mortgage, a
car, and my mom, Shirley said, Harold,
what, you know, how can we save half of
our income? We have three kids in a home,
we can't afford it.
And my father said we can't afford not to.
And that sort of set the theme,
I think of how, you know,
he approached life and he was,
um,
uh, he was born a hip in poverty,
you know, he had no money.
Um, and uh, you know,
when he was a child, uh,
I just, I don't want to keep
going, but there was a, um, he, uh,
there's a story about him where he was
eight years old and he felt like he
wanted to make some money.
So he sat in the candy store right
near the tenement where he grew up.
And in those days people didn't have
telephones. So my dad would sit,
the phone would ring in the candy
store and he'd get up and say, oh,
call call from Mrs. Jones, Mrs.
Jones phone call. You go out.
And Mrs. Jones would come down the
stairs and give him a nickel or dime,
you know, he'd get a tip
and he was in a candy store.
So we always used to say to my kids,
do you think, what did I do with it?
My kids are like, new Bob Candy,
all the candy. And he said, no,
I saved it.
And gave it to my parents.
And because he knew the
delayed gratification there
was his parents wouldn't
fight as much and they'd have bread on
the table. And that kind of, you know,
I,
I hesitate sometimes to tell that story
cause not everyone's Harold like that is
extraordinary to be eight years old.
Um, but, and, and not eat the candy.
But I think that that kind of thinking
for kids and even telling those stories,
kids love anecdotes. You tell
them the story, they're like,
oh it could be like Harold,
maybe we'll make a little Harold doll.
Um, we're gonna open it up to
questions in a couple of minutes.
So if you have questions you can line
up at the two microphones in the aisles.
But I wanted to ask you about something
else cause you actually in the book
normally like in general,
I often think of good parenting
advice is being based on openness and
communication.
But there are some things about parents'
finances that you advocate keeping
private, which I found
especially interesting because
my parents are divorced,
which I think brings money, talk out
into the open in a very different way.
And there were, you know, in terms of
child support and who could afford what,
and it can be fraught,
but it also,
you hear a lot more from your parents
maybe because they're just talking through
you instead of to each other.
So what are some of the things that
at different ages you think parents
shouldn't talk to their
kids about? Right. I mean,
I think that when children
are five, six, seven,
eight, nine, you don't have to, I mean,
telling them what your salary
is to me is just out of context.
Like they don't have anywhere to put it.
So if you're like,
I make $100,000 a year, well then why
can't I get that candy bar? You know?
And you could explain it,
but I think the numbers are
meaningless to very young children.
I think as kids get older, you know, I,
I've been having a lot of
questions from parents.
My 16 year old wants to know how much
I make and should I tell her or not.
And in those cases, I think particularly
if you're there, you start thinking,
and this one mom was,
we were talking about it and she realized
because her daughter was nervous about
college, which you'll be able to afford
it. Would she be able to, should you know,
she tried to get into the best school
or would she just not be able to go?
So those kind of cool,
I think those,
but I think you don't have
to tell you you should. Well,
the ideal is not to fight in front
of your kids about money. Um,
they actually said that when parents fight
a lot in front there, his about money,
those kids are three times more likely
to have $500 or more in credit card debt
in college. Um, I think
that, uh, trying to,
you know,
you don't just talk to your kids about
is just got to be age appropriate. Like,
oh, am I 401k went down, you know,
they're, they don't care or, or,
right. I'm frightened about paying
for college. So there's anxiety. Yeah.
It can be passed along to kids. That's,
I don't think it's a healthy thing.
Yeah. The, the balance between being
conscientious and being anxious,
kids pick up on that worry and definitely.
Yeah.
And on that wonderful happy note,
let's take it to the audience who
can maybe turn the things around you.
Wanna go ahead.
Yeah, absolutely. My sister. Yeah. Yeah.
Great. Speaking to it. So first of all,
I want to say thank you for being here.
Um, I would some number of years ago,
I won't say how many, uh, I
managed to get a copy of, uh,
get a financial life and it helped
me tremendously. Thank my twenties,
so thank you. Um, you know,
been flipping through the book
for the first time just now.
And I think one of the things like,
we can acknowledge that Google
pays ridiculously well. No,
nobody here deserves to make nearly
as much money as they do. So.
So I think a lot of Googlers
are in a fairly, yeah.
Um, and you know, so I see
things in your book about like,
don't worry about keeping up
with the Kardashians, you know,
don't buy your kid a car. I think, you
know, just my own experience. Right.
Those weren't options growing up.
Absolutely. And you know, it was parent,
my kids are 10 and 12. We're
at this point where like, Gosh,
a lot of your friends have all this
stuff and it's certainly, you know, it's,
it's a want but it's certainly like within
the range of affordability for us and,
and sort of figuring out that line
between am I denying you and making you an
outcast socially things that
you could be doing. I mean,
every high school kid in my
town has a car and you know,
the idea of not doing that.
So I'm sort of curious on how you
make that trade off if you have any
information on like,
you know,
teaching kids the hard lessons
versus like making them an outcast,
that sort of thing.
I love that question and I've heard it
in different communities and I think that
a lot of people who have grew
up middle class or you know,
really struggling or,
and then you,
you're at Google or you are making a
lot of money or you have a lot of money,
it's very difficult.
Personally,
I'm all about denial to my
children. Not Completely, but I,
my daughter was last one to get herself
bone. You know, everybody we know.
And I think that,
I think it was so ingrained in me like
these values in my head and also I'm
writing about this, but to be
fair, but I think that, um,
by the time,
you know,
if I think delaying first
of all in just as a mom,
I'm saying this in much technology is
so much better because kids are still
reading books and they're
still communicating and
talking and looking you in the
eye. And I think that, you know,
my classic story was when my
daughter, who's now 21, um,
when she was 13, she said, we're
going, I'm going with some friends.
We live in Manhattan. Uh, we're
going to go, can we go to Macy's?
And we were a little over protective.
She was our first child. And we're like,
okay, you can go. And she's like an,
all my friends have a credit card,
like their parent's credit card where
one is a debit card. And the parents,
they were good parents. They gave them a
limit. But I said, absolutely not. I said,
I'm going to give you cash. And he's like,
all right. You know, she didn't, you know,
she's a little embarrassed. Um, and,
but she went and she
used cash and she said,
you know what,
you gave me $100 mom and it was
$103 so I had to put something back.
Whereas if you hand your kid a card,
a prepaid card, even, you know,
you can put it exactly the limit,
but often it's like off of your town and,
and if your kid comes back and spends
$120, you're like, Oh, good job. You know,
you didn't spend $4,000.
You know,
and I think that the cash and talking
about it with kids because you know,
it's trickier with everything now,
you know,
with Venmo and I just felt
up through high school,
up through college, they did not need
to have experiences with plastic.
And I think parents also an interesting
thing I've been hearing is that,
oh, but we're worried about our kids not
having a credit report or credit record.
And that to me feels very insidious
in that they're the notion of needing,
you will get a credit card
when you graduate from college.
They will not be a problem getting a
credit card. And I think they're just,
because now it's credit Karma,
which I like. You get it for free,
your credit score. But I think that
people are rushing it too much.
So in terms,
I think if you talk and say,
I know you're the last one in
your grade to get, you know,
a phone and that's just the way we
feel and we understand it can be hard.
I understand. But you know,
and yeah, those people, I
mean, I always hear often like,
oh, those people have a summer
house or those people have,
and it's like we have,
we have such a good family.
We're so lucky, you know, and
everybody makes different choices.
And this is the choice we make and
we love you just as much in those.
I mean, it sounds so trite, right?
And I'm um, you don't have to say yes.
It's like, yeah, it's
really trite now. Um,
but that idea of those
kinds of conversations, and
again, I was lucky I was,
when my family, we had those conversations
and I still sort of, we still,
my husband and I still have those
conversations with our kids and it just
explaining, and I have to say,
when I see the next phase,
and I've been interviewing lots of kids,
you know,
kids 2122 and talking about it.
And some of you are probably close to
that age and you know, the whole, yeah,
not really. You know your
generation, by the way, the,
the millennial generation has much less
credit card debt than Gen Xers in their
20s or baby boomers in their twenties.
And that's probably because in 2009
President Obama passed the card act,
which said you have to be 21 to get a
credit card in college unless a parent
co-signs never do that, never
cosigned a credit card with your kid.
I've met so many parents who said,
yeah, we did my credit right breeding,
I could use my cart. And so
never do that. And also just,
I would say wait till junior year in high
in college before or suggest to them,
okay, if you have a job you can get a
credit card, pay it off immediately.
But personally I've seen,
you know,
freshman year they have to do laundry for
the first time, you know, not all kids,
but my kids, they have to do
laundry and there are a lot going.
There's a lot going on.
Freshman year they're studying hard and
they're trying to figure it all out.
And I think adding credit to the mix.
I mean I again,
when I graduated in 1986 from,
call it CDC, yeah, 86 from college.
Everyone I knew had lots of credit card
debt because it was handed out. You know,
someone's like, yeah, I went to a frat
party, I got a credit card, you know,
it's just like handed out. So I hope that
helps. Thank you very much. All right,
thank you.
I, I've been, uh, I've been trying to
figure out how to ask this question. Um,
and I think the marshmallow
example is probably the best
way to do it, please. Um,
there's probably not hard data on it,
but I was just wondering if you
had an opinion on it based on your,
your knowledge,
what's too early?
Like it's very tempting for my kid.
It's just very responsive to all kinds
of different things we threw at him.
It's very tempting to say like,
okay, you know what, you're too,
here's a marshmallow and then see
you fail and you know, and you know,
then we'll try again in a few months.
Maybe that's a little damage.
And I'm wondering if you
have a thought on that.
That's a great, another
great real question. Um,
so when I was reading about the
marshmallow experiment and there were,
I looked at his original papers and,
and then I went online and they're like,
all these parents, here's
a marshmallow but don't eat
it. I'm like, oh my goodness,
why I want it. Um, and I,
you know, wrote in the book,
like you just want to go buy a bag of
marshmallows and go into the covers and
eat them yourself. You know? So I think
that, I think that's a great question.
If you,
I,
I'm happy and I pride myself on
my book being researched based.
But I think when you're looking
at being a parent and being,
sometimes it's better not to
have the research in your head.
And I think,
you know,
certainly my dad didn't have any
of that research in his head.
And it's sort of like,
I think with that knowledge sometimes
can come anxiety like word is my kid fall
on the scale.
And I gotta Tell Ya,
this is something my mom
would say all the time.
There are always bumps in the roads with
kids and they'll be there. So great.
Oh, the teachers said they're
not paying attendant. Oh,
because they're writing math code under
the desk in second grade, you know,
whatever it is. I made that up. I
was not that good. It's like a great,
but I think that,
I think that,
I strongly believe it's good to know
this stuff and to think about it a little
bit. And it's fun. Like when it crops
up, you know, you're like, oh, you know,
but I would not be testing
kits because it will bill it.
Start getting a little anxious probably
or feeling that I'm being tested.
So I would say it's just the parenting,
the daily life of parenting.
Wow. We look at that house.
That's a beautiful house one day. You
know, maybe if we save up a lot of money,
maybe we'll get that house or,
yeah, yeah. We saved a lot that,
so we're going on a vacation. I'm so
excited. You know, just making it a,
not a sort of part of
everyday conversation in life.
And it does take more effort for your
generation to do that because again,
you're not saying let's take a trip
to the bank or I dunno, you know,
opening a bank account
is a great thing to do,
but I mean the interest rate
is 0.1% but that's like,
that's almost the point in terms of
just having that experience of going to
bank.
I mean some,
some banks still have passbook savings
accounts and of course make sure they
don't have fees cause your kid will put
in $10 but it's gone then that's next
month.
But that helpful at all.
Hello. So, uh, my wife
and I have a disagreement.
I've started paying my eight year old
for each time he practices the piano.
I can give him a dime each time he does
it. And if he does it for a whole week,
I give them a dollar.
Um,
she thinks it takes some of the joy out
of playing the piano because he's doing
it for money now. Perhaps it
enhances the joy. I think so.
So what do you think about paying
kids for chores and General? Yeah.
Yeah. I mean again, the research,
when you look at sort of the idea of
doing chores now that's different cause
piano. So when you, you're
talking about chores,
I think it's not a good idea
to tie regular family chores.
Like everybody has to have a job.
I used to load the dishwasher,
empty the dishwasher, you know,
and make my bed, whatever it is.
That's something I had to do. If you're
talking about one off things like okay,
you know, could you, I don't know. I
haven't lived in a house in a long time.
Would he do like get the leaves
out of the whatever, a garage,
clean up,
clean the garage I made an interesting
distinction you make in the book is to
that you can pay children for chores
that if they weren't doing it,
you might hire someone to do exactly.
But the, the regular maintenance,
regular maintenance. So where does
piano fit into that? I feel like,
is that like paying for studying?
It's a little like paying for grades,
which again, Roland Fryer's randomized
control study showed it to on average,
it just doesn't matter.
It doesn't help.
Now he also found,
um,
which is if you're talking
about small one off project,
so maybe it would fit into
like just completed that day.
If you complete it five times, I'm going
to reward you at the end of the week.
I mean he was saying that that can
help a child achieve a small term goal,
but the end of the day,
and it's funny,
my husband and I had this one because
when I was a kid I took piano lessons and
I know now I can eight years
and now I can't play a thing.
He was more like improvisational
and played when he felt like it.
And I,
and you know,
two of our three kids ended up being like
that and I was sorta nervous like why
aren't they taking piano lessons? And,
but so I think that I would in your case,
probably side with your wife, sorry, we
could call her on the phone. Yes. What?
Um,
but in the sense that in the end,
the point of it is they're loving
playing piano and there and I think that,
um,
no matter what value you give to it,
you want the value for your child to,
to eventually come from them.
And I pretty strongly feel that in my,
you know, control group of
three, then my brother and me,
like when it was sort of demanded or
paid for or we weren't paid for it.
But just that maybe that probably
if your title is being paid for it,
maybe there's something else they
would pick that they really want to do,
that they would spend the time
doing. So it, it's a tricky one and,
but I would side with not
paying for playing the piano.
All right. Thank you.
Thank you. Okay. Sorry.
But you don't have to tell your
wife. Hey, never happened. Yeah.
My Dad has a question. Grabbed the
microphone for him if you want.
Oh, thank you. I'd like
to tell you, first of all,
I've been retired 26 years
and uh,
I was on a cruise
a few years ago and a guy
was sitting next to me
and he said, um, what
do you do? I said, well,
I'm an educator and schools and so on.
Just how long have you
been retired at that point?
I said about 23 years.
So he looked at me and he said,
how do you survive now the problem I
think that the country is heading in to is
the problem of people are living
longer and by living longer,
you're going to have need finance's
over a longer period of time.
And if you don't have it,
if you don't have it,
it's going to cause major problems.
Whether it's social security,
you don't have enough, but it'll,
it'll aggravate the situation.
And I think we have to address that,
that your children should
be educated enough to save.
My wife,
we were married 65 years and my
wife and I went on our first trip,
major trip to Europe,
celebrating our 25th anniversary.
But we would constantly,
when she said to my I by wife am I said,
we're going to,
uh,
we're going to take that
tax deferred annuity.
Now we must do it by Osaka
to jobs to supplement it.
I ran a college entrance coachy course.
Remember the Stanley Kaplan?
Yeah.
Here's his competitor family one.
He did very well, but, uh,
he was a teacher in New York
City school system by the way.
He was teacher of economics
and Chuck Schumer,
the Senate Minority Leader for the
Democrats was a kid in James Madison high
school in Brooklyn and he offered to give
the kids free coaching course if they
do his mimeograph eworks
duplicating his notes. And that's,
we started by the way, he was
teacher of economics. But anyway,
to get it back to this,
it's crucial for our
country's future to plan,
helping our children become
independent and not dependent.
I've had no problems
being retired 26 years.
Okay. And it's something
that you have to play in.
Well,
I didn't get that lacoss cost shirt.
I always wanted to open
one chapter in that. Like,
I wanted an alligator shirt and then my
aunt gave us a bag of clothes from my,
or like wealthier cousins
and there was an alligator,
so I cut it off and so did on my sweater.
And of course this mean girl said
that's not a real alligator sweater.
You sewed that on and that was like, oh,
but I mean those things you remember,
but we had such a great childhood
and I only have, you know,
it's sort of interesting how that kind
of philosophy is just I think the heart
of it. All right. Thank
you so much. Thank you.
One last quick question.
Yeah. So I'm not sure if it falls under
a financial education or more child
psychology, but going back to the Pete
getting paid for piano list, right?
For practicing the piano.
I want to ask the other way around.
Let's say my kid does something I really
don't like her doing and I'm willing to
pay her for not doing it right.
How would that be done?
It'd be done.
I would also say that shouldn't be done
because they have to learn. I mean, again,
I'm not a psychologist, so take it with
a grain of salt. But I think in terms of,
you know, the stuff I've read
that it's the same thing.
You don't want to say a child does.
Well if I misbehave, first of all,
you're giving them a
perverse incentive that okay,
I misbehave and then I get money to stop
it. So at first I'm gonna Misbehave,
then I'll get paid to stop
doing it. Um, right. Does that
make sense? But also that,
um, it should be come from
within. Like I am going to not,
I'm not going to misbehave because it
really bugs my dad and I don't want to bug
me dad because he's a nice dad or I want
to, you know, I think those kind of,
again,
you're giving an external x
extrinsic reward or you know,
or disincentive,
you know,
something money or whatever to do to
change your behavior I think is not a good
thing for children because that children
have to understand intrinsically why
it's good to be good or to, you know,
or to listen or to stop being bad.
And I think it confuses
it. Thanks. Thank you.
And that's, that's all the time we have
for today, but thank you so much, Beth.
Thanks.
Thank you so much.